c'était une promesse de campagne voisins
le bretonneux a mis en circulation ce
mardi 12 avril sa vie si navette un
minibus pour les seniors l'idée de la
vie si navette est née de la
questionnaire qu'on avait fait il ya
deux ou trois ans auprès des seniors et
puis de l'analyse des besoins sociaux
qu'on est en train de terminer qui
montrait que beaucoup de gens restés un
peu isolé parce que le déplacement intra
muros dans la commune était un petit peu
complexe la navette desservira très art
et les mardis et les jeudis matins dans
le des points stratégiques de la ville
deux allers retours sont prévus par
matinée là par exemple on est dans le
centre commercial de la grande île mais
l'arrêt suivant c'est le centre
commercial de la bretonnière pour avant
d'arriver au centre commercial du centre
ville vous avez la poste la mairie
centre culturel decauville vous
l'apprendrez puisse arrêter quelque part
est allé faire une promenade à pied à
l'autre bout de la commune je pense par
exemple à la croix du bois une façon
pour la commune de lutter contre
l'isolément chez les plus âgés on sait
qu'il ya des gens isolés de parts soit
parce qu'ils connaissent pas grand monde
soit parce que ils n'ont pas de moyen de
déplacement la façon dont la ville est
faite fait les gens vivent beaucoup au
fait recentrer sur leur quartier et
c'est aussi l'occasion pour des vices
ynwa qui le souhaitent pas de connaître
un petit peu mieux leur commune en se
promenant de quartier en quartier pour
l'instant le minibus n'en est qu'à son
stade d'essai les horaires et le trajet
vont être adaptés en fonction des
retours des utilisateurs pour bénéficier
de la navette il suffit de se rendre sur
l'un des arrêts desservis le service est
pour l'instant gratuit jusqu'à fin juin